hey Anna vanson here and I recently went
on the Mario Kart Bowser's challenge
ride at Super Nintendo World and let me
tell you it is one of the most detailed
Laden cues I have ever seen like I saw
75 book titles in one of the rooms I'm
not gonna list all of them but a few of
my favorites are Cloudy with a Chance of
pain a romantic's guide to falling in
lava party games for friends and enemies
a Mario Party reference Inside Story
Probably referencing the game Bowser's
Inside Story and unthomp yourself which
I'm pretty sure is a parody of the book
on yourself if you go on that ride be
sure to keep your eyes peeled for those
books and even more in Bowser's study